and we want to welcome to this video
playing in mortal and promote inner
balance I've got 10.5 out of 11 and this
is a good score so let's hope it will
stay that way and now that I'm on 2500
it would be cool to ya to have the good
customers deliver points like they
usually do and need them and ok some
sort wikia for opening him threatening
now to take the porn a four-win the poem
ok ok I'll just cancel you Wow ok let's
open up the position ac4 looks really
strange LF takes Knight eggs as 93 which
is pretty annoying and here I thought
everything is good basically but this
looks even more powerful than the rest
ok I can take antique again and whoa ok
I see the point night at five but ok i'm
just taking this and open up the whole
stuff he would probably play d5 here I
guess maybe I should have played queen
to d6 first and do that now I don't want
to trade queen squad Clary and
no time to waste mh3 Queen h2 I guess
hmm would like to try to prevent that
somehow if possible when idea is not
doing anything at all
night night over here would be cool like
rite f-86 but he has g5 all the time
this is what irritates me quite a bit
okay either I don't know I just don't
know I thought this Queenie six but he's
got rookie one this is actually quite
quite annoying okay doesn't look very
logical or anything but I had to play
something so what now is he maybe
prepare 94
still has a g5 business him yea my queen
isn't isn't it it doesn't have any any
concept here right I'm just running
around without any purpose and not good
not good at all yeah this looks more
than dangerous a route coming to see one
would be very dangerous should I don't
want to drag queens but I'm probably
happy now if that actually happens with
my king in such bad shape yeah and this
this is against the player who have
beaten senselessly in the past row and
against that dead opening wow it's okay
need to try to swindle air that's
definitely still possible i mean the
position is quite quite awake him came
antigua the porn unfortunately wow wow
wow wow
Roxy one looks pretty bad and maybe 93
oh no this one and he's playing well all
of a sudden in other games I always be
the check and now he plays well that's
not fair why don't you play badly
yeah I guess I really have to swing Liam
completely lost here this is nonsense
and it after that opening this is what I
cannot get my head around it was really
really bad it was an absolutely terrible
opening for wine
Roxy to something would be cool but you
can even just take on this having a
couple of times and with the rook ending
okay if you place Butchie 7i 0 c1 have a
couple of checks it's probably still
losing but
as long as my king is reasonably safe I
will continue Jack him so it seems that
he's confident that this is the win Jeff
I'm not sure maybe it is I wouldn't have
risked that to be perfectly honest but
so here he's got the time morning check
ok I can tick he actually said something
better ok I have to do this it's not
ideal but at least I'm escaping into
some kind of book ending it's probably
probably still losing and check that is
losing unfortunately check everyone the
six actually terrible terrible and what
a shitty game jam playing him and Jackie
really does this a lot you have to make
things interesting again check check
check
check I should probably resign what's a
bad guy there's a still always
frustrating after such a such a bonkers
opening from white man stuff like 92 and
c4 is just pretty pretty horrendous okay
so before I look good maybe it is what
kind of opening is that maybe it is not
so bad I mean it just it looks terrible
but maybe it's not so bad he's got two
bishops and the position is murky it
definitely is murky I think this is
probably not correct I think this is
probably not right the engine wants to
play rook h6 and gingi 5 immediately
that's probably d 5 m and the bishops
come to life and in this him it's
completely completely weird I thought
during the game that this should be a
good for black due to White's wacky King
position but it doesn't seem to be an ta
it's just entirely out clear and yeah
and this this is not good now why this
why does a lot better and they have to
yeah start to swindle which Jack wasn't
what and so I'm winning here was not
winning I have rookie 5 oh my god so
where this is why i'm usually winning
against him because he blunders and no i
didn't see it Ruby five and over ah I
was stupid and Jan now that was a
terrible again and I ever play like that
I can forget to keep roughly 2500 this
was just absolutely atrocious who
thanks for watching